va revenir sur ce qui s'est passé dans
la nuit c'est bien sûr la tempête karane
qui a frappé la France et en particulier
l'ouest du pays des records de vent ont
été battu en particulier dans le
finisterère il y a eu beaucoup de dégâts
matériels mais également deux décès et
plusieurs blessés à déplorer dans un
instant Jérémy restaurateur à Arzon en
Bretagne qui a vu sa terrasse arrachée
sera avec nous pour nous raconter
comment il a vécu cette tempête ERC
brocardi l'excellent Éric brocardi
porte-parole des sapeurs pompiers sera
avec nous également et Alexandra blanc
journaliste météo C news nous dira si le
pire est derrière nous et je pense que
rayon va être très intéressé par la
météo du jour on va regarder ce qui
s'est passé dans l'ouest du pays lors du
passage de la tempête
[Musique]
déjà
voilà à quoi ça ressemble il reste plus
rien merci d'être avec nous merci Eric
brocardi porte-parole des sapeurs
pompiers c'est toujours un bonheur de
vous avoir merci Alexandra qui vient
nous voir une collègue de de C news vous
allez nous dire ce qui va se passer dans
les dans les prochains jours merci
d'être là Alexandra blanc et on a Jérémy
restaurateur à Arzon qui lui on va voir
la vidéo de votre restaurant V terrasse
restaurant vous allevez retrouvé des
morceaux je à 200 m de votre restaurant
c'est un truc de fou
[Applaudissements]
regardez c'est un truc de fou hein alors
com ça ça comment vous avez vous avez
vécu ça parce c'est un truc de fou
euh vous attend ou pas vous attendit ou
pas vous avez pas du tout ouais c'est ça
vous êtes dit c'est parce que on se dit
à chaque fois bon ça va être ça va être
très très violent mais là c'est vrai que
c'est c'est un truc de fou on se dit pas
on se dit que ça va tenir de toute façon
c'est quand on quand on m'appelle à à
23h et qu'on me dit il faut que tu
viennes maintenant
vous aviez fermé on avait ferméou bien
sûr bah oui ouais c'est c'est des
voisins restaurateurs qui m'ont appelé
que je remercie beaucoup et qui m'ont
appelé qui m'ont dit il faut que tu
viennes maintenant appelle les pompiers
et puis faut sécuriser tout ça parce que
c'est alors le maire de votre filleon a
d'ailleurs témoigné aujourd'hui dans les
médias qu'il y a eu de nombreux dégâts
regardez je suis sur le pont pour
reloger certains habitants euh et aussi
reloger certains saisonniers de nos
commerçants qui avaient un contrat dans
nos campigns et donc nous trouvons des
solutions pour reloger ces personnes
beaucoup de dégâts arzonoui nous avons
énormément de dégâts sur Arzon
d'ailleurs nous attendons enedis
l'intervention d'enedis depuis ce matin
on les relance on les relance mais nous
ne sommes pas prioritaires vu les dégâts
qu'il y a sur toute la Bretagne mais il
y a un deuxième coup de vent qui arrive
dès samedi matin et ma crainte c'est que
des arbres qui ont été fragilisé par
cette première tempête est tenue et ne
tiennent pas encore pour samedi autre
image forte c'est ces grues qui sont
tombées à Brest
regardez
et la team j'ai entendu un gros boom la
grue elle est tombé
incroyable la grue elle est
tombée beaucoup de dégâts éc brocardi
porte-parole de la Fédération nationale
des sapeurs pompiers moi je j'ai
toujours je suis toujours angoissé pour
vous moi quand il se passe des choses
comme ça aussi parce qu'on dit à tout le
monde de rentrer pour soi mais on dit à
tous les pompiers justementant en
faitant autres r chez vous REC nous on
va avant c'est un comment comment on
prépare ça Eric parce que c'est vrai que
c'est je me dis on n'est pas on n'est
pas tellement confronté à ça en France
comment on prépare un truc comme ça déjà
c'est mécaniquement c'est sur une
stratégie opérationnelle qui repose un
sur la solidarité entre les territoires
avec du prépositionnement et une
anticipation c'est-à-dire qu'en gros on
va on sait qu'il va y avoir des
intempéries à un moment donné qui vont
frapper et donc la justesse est
d'adapter en fonction des risques qui
vont être liés et qui vont être traduit
au centre opérationnel départemental
autour du préfet qui vont nous permettre
d'ajuster les moyens bien en amont et la
clé de la réussite c'est l'anticipation
et les messages de diffusion lancé à la
population parce que objectivement on
est vraiment sur un palier de niauation
PZ faire quoi vous en fait mais là ce
que l'on peut dire et ce que l'on peut
faire c'est un garantir des conseils de
prévention qui soient écoutés auprès de
la population deuxièmement d'intervenir
en cas de nécessité et de dangers
imminents et secourir la population
rapidement donc on a cette force de
frappe rapide et on a aussi cette
expertise de reconnaissance qui vont
permettre d'adapter les moyens pour
secourir les les les passants et
secourir tout le monde avec des moyens
ajustés des moyens précis parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans des
phases où voilà on doit déblayer on doit
permettre aussi de travailler en
interservice avec les autres forces de
secours et les autres services
techniques des mairie qui ont été
fortement sollicités et je pense qu'on
peut féliciter l'ensemble des services
publics et toutes les unités parce que
aujourd'hui on est dans une phase de
résilience des territoires qui fait que
on est sur voilà une optimisation des
moyens et puis voilà comme je dis je le
répète il faut vraiment saluer cette
force là qui a mis du temps de
l'engagement de la disponibilité et
surtout la nuit et surtout en période de
congé très clairement voilà ils ont
donné de leur personne on a vu en
Bretagne une vague gigantesque
surprendre certaines personnes qui avent
pris des risques regardez
ça regardez ça qui fait ça qu'est-ce
qu'il fait
là
attendement Dang les gars ah ou mais
voilà bah ça ça c'est er ça c'est c'est
ce qu'on se dit c'est tout ce qu'il faut
pas faire c'est exactement tout ce qu'il
faut pas faire c'est on va dire de
manière générale la curiosité faut la
laisser au garage dans ces grands
momentsl euh je pense que ça sert à rien
de mettre en danger des sapeurs pompiers
pour aller secourir des gens qui sont là
pour faire des photos c'est vrai que
c'est ça reste magnifique un spectacle
naturel comme celui-ci mais je pense
qu'il faut proprement parler avoir une
raison de rester chez soi et ça fait
partie de la culture de sécurité civile
qu'on doit avoir et qu'on doit apprendre
à l'école dès le plus jeune âge pour pas
se mettre en danger et faire preuve de
solidarité je crois que la solidarité
aujourd'hui on en a besoin ça été montré
avec un exemple tout à l'heure dans un
conflit du Proche Orient donc voilà il
faut montrer aussi cette force on a se
raisonner entre nous euh même si les
diggas sont majoritairement des dégâts
matériels malheureusement deux personnes
ont perdu la vie et 15 autres personnes
ont été blessé au total dont SEP sa
peeur pompiers on pense fort à eux quand
je disais que c'est pour vous aussi je
suis le plus inquiet à chaque fois qu'il
y a des il y a des a des événements
comme ça le premier déc c'est un
chauffeur routier qui a perdu la vie
dans un accident de la route dans l'aine
avec un arbre tombé sur le camion pense
fort à sa famille à lui qui il a voulu
absolument faire son travail travailler
et vraiment on pense à lui ça c'est
c'est je vous dis ça c'est c'estement
horrible et un homme de 70 an une
affaire incroyable est mort après un
coup de vent l'homme aurait chulté de
son balcon alors qu'il était en train de
fermer son volet près du Avre Gill ou
ouz c'est un un coup de vent il a été
pris alors le bilan c'est de morts c'est
dramatique des blessés mais quand même
globalement on a l'impression que la
prévention a fonctionné le système
d'alerte les préfets ont pris des
arrêtés rester chez vous le ministre de
l'Intérieur avait dit est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça on ach peut-être
encore à la réponse est directe et
franche oui même si on a l'impression de
priver certaines liberté mais c'est pour
la vie des gens que l'on fait ça et que
l'on exerce aujourd'hui des arrêtés
préfectoraux pour permettre justement de
laisser les gens chez soi d'éviter
qu'ils prennent des transports qui vont
à un moment donné exposer les gens à un
risque particulier les gens comprenaient
pas pourquoi on arrête les trains mais
c'est simple parce que si les trains
sont barrés sur leur leur rail avec des
branchages c'est des gens que l'on
expose à l'intérieur un risque le temps
qu'on attende de libérer la voie donc le
sujet aujourd'hui c'est de sortir de ces
de ce phénomène de confort qui veut
qu'aujourd'hui bah quand on a une
vigilance rouge comme même quand une
vigilance orange puisque on rappelle que
malheureusement c'est décès on est en
vigilance Orange il est constaté aussi
qu'il faut être extrêmement vigilant en
permanence et donc d'adopter le bon
comportement alors Jérémy quels sont les
les les dégâts de votre restaurant toute
la terrasse effondrée tout tout à tout à
refaire c'est vous pouvez pas travailler
là pour l'instant non non ben vous voyez
l'entrée sur votre droite là tout est
devant ahouais ou euh le toit à gauche
est encore
encore fragile donc on a on a appelé on
a appelé des gens en urgence pour pour
démonter ça parce que parce que c'est
les les Assur les assurances vont vont
prendre en charge bien entendu beaucoup
de choses mais il paraît que pas tout
alors pas tout le temps c'est très
longent faut déjà que ce soit déclaré
catastrophe naturel après est-ce que
c'est privé est-ce que c'est l'état
c'est très compliqué et le problème
aussi c'est que il y a tellement
d'expertise à faire il y a pas assez
d'experts donc il faut souhaiter que ça
aille très vite parce que les gens
peuvent pas rester comme ça alors
Alexandra vous êtes journaliste météo
bien sûr sur ces news est-ce que la
tempête a été plus sévère que prévu
alors non elle n'a pas été plus sévère
que prévu en tout cas les vents ont été
particulièrement fort c'est on peut à
peu près a comparé à la tempête de 1999
puisqu'on a eu localement plus de 200
kmh de vent sur la pointe du rat je ne
sais pas si vous vous imaginer ce sont
des vents tempétueux quasiment du jamais
vu on a d'ailleurs battu des records de
vent des records de rafales de vent par
rapport à ce que nous avions connu en
1987 ou encore en
1999 mais la différence c'est que là on
a été mieux préparé c'est ce qu'on
disait avec Eric brocardi c'est que par
rapport à 1999 on a été un petit peu
mieux préparé c'est vrai que les les les
données météorologiques ont également
beaucoup évolué mais en attendant les
vents ont été particulièrement fort
c'est une tempête d'une intensité
exceptionnelle on parlait d'une bombe
météorologique elle a bien eu lieu elle
a balayé vraiment tous les pays toutes
les le nord-ouest de la France mais
également les côtes de la Manche où l'on
a eu des vents particulièrement fort et
tempétueux alors est-ce que le cette
tempête est finie le le pire est
derrière nous ça y est ou pas alors oui
le pire est derrière nous c'est une
tempête donc exceptionnel on en a pas
tous les ans mais on va avoir de nouveau
un temps très agité à partir de demain
avec de nouveau une nouvelle dépression
qui va concerner cette fois le sud-ouest
de la France là ça a concerner la
Bretagne et les côtes de la Manche là on
va retrouver cette deuxème dépression un
petit peu plus au sud donc entre la
Gironde et l'élande et puis on parle
d'une nouvelle tempête he on en parle
tous entre samedi et dimanche alors
rassurez-vous cette tempête s'appelle
Domingo c'est pas vraiment une tempête
c'est plutôt une dépression hein qui va
balayer euh le sud-ouest du pays a
priori ce serait euh les charanttin ou
encore la Vendée qui serait
principalement concerné donc finalement
tout le monde à un moment donné sera
concerné par ces ventes empétuux mais
qui s'annonce beaucoup moins fort on
aura pas 200 kmh de vent cyil
rassurez-vous on aura 120 130 mais ça
reste assez fort et on a des défilés de
perturbation avec des systèmes
dépressionnaires assez importants on
maintenant dans
l'émission le pire derrière nous c'est
ce que disaient les gens qui croisaient
Raymond pendant ses
vacances merci en tout cas merci
Alexandra et merci merci d'avoir été
avec nous j'espère que Jérémy que votre
restaurant va pouvoir retravailler assez
vite on va pas